これじゃあはじめ雪をですあの北
そう大好きなんですよ人が出せない音量とか人だとどうしようもないような音が出る
ものってすっげー魅力的だと思いませんだってそれ人間超えてますからねなんで今まで
色々ドラとか
ええっ
運動がのパーンとか
いろんな層がでもの求道を起こしてきたりしてなんですけども今回のは多分お金僕の
あの人間的な感覚からすると過去最強にうるさいですこちらジェットホーンていうやつ
でございますちょっとどこら辺がちょっと品かわかんないんですけどまぁなんか見てろ
と言いこれトランペットみたいな音ガッキーみたいになってるんですけど体感としては
もう耳元でやると魂9階
発で破れるくらい危険ですことが
[音楽]
だーっ
アップねぇ右がもうやばいん
goo
[音楽]
の
あっほしー
すっえっ私死んでるっ
はっ
わっいっても言えばカチッ吊るし待ってすんどれかも知れ
[音楽]
何をよええ
んはぁっ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
8ん
ニッ
入ってゆけこれぐらいやばいんですけどもこんなサイズのラッパでこの音が出るって事
はこれもっと音をこのラッパ増のここもっとでかくしたらもっと音が拡張されて
さらなる教義的なバッグを出せるんじゃないかなと思いまして
はいこちら命が品ですこれ何とか総理させたら音量が長杯カシメつぶさになると思う
わけですよ
でガムテープでも
google 負けだな比べてみます1回普通に直します
[音楽]
やっつけますなんだこれ聴いてるからダメと期末配当を見て完成しました
z 品2名が本をつけてデカイ音をさらにこれで拡張させるというも地図を最悪の間
薬草マシンが完成しましたらせます
もうやだもう俺は際はいけます
深い音が深い
[音楽]
ban
じゃあバイバイッ
goo
えっ
8あーうざいなんかわかんないす体感的にはこう広がってたのはさらにこうまとまって
1点を貫く感じになってるんでこれで捧ぐ公平を起こしてみましょうではいかんよ
me
[音楽]
voodoo
ああああ
凶悪でさあこれマジですよに1階丸焼くだけ
史上最強じゃね結構それって結構何んだと思う
じゃわよね
[音楽]